and he's involved in that in police I'm
the Norman Doidge walk a game in feeling
mr. McLeish are my global design
barbarous in the SU contraseña schema up
communists are fine but one hour work to
build carbon-free renewable and circle
economy that work is begin begins now it
is a huge signal to the financial world
only zero carbon solutions will pay off
Oakland Blake upon a composite seriously
for weaklings London isn't amidst
accounts the seguin see the new beats
new Giovanni MSC say aura i gain
assurance key starter here called sesto
total chiodos ah no shine tell alkyne
mentioned for us in the scar flashed
then one star on Hindon free dimension
rested to chemical la esta te amo [ __ ]
ha ha de Coulomb fe la Mer Tom otra vida
yo Jerry motto and now who's out on her
see ballad la ocupa el abra la higuera
cry
the agency will be able to deploy
equipment and a standing reserve of at
least 1,500 border guards from member
states through Schengen we have agreed
to have one external border of the EU
and no internal borders amusement of you
losing improv I'm starting example Shing
in the arm in key fatso jetson if a
country is both failing to control its
borders and refusing to ask for help
then we should offer them a choice take
the help or the rest of the EU will be
within its rights to take action from my
perspective the crisis is not over and
there should be no complacency decayed
intervent a few inches EV all tiara for
cemento de la domanda interna del
aspetta DVD set or privado SAP a seagull
mo paddy McCann is no quiso no sector
public Issa Sesay been fiscally take
immense a subpoena budget Lozano hoof
aggressive tax avoidance and evasion
cost the EU a trillion euros a year
there's a strong consensus in this house
for real hard-hitting action to be taken
against tax dodging there is no excuse
for us to not implement these measures
breastscreen time has come for us to be
one
set aside all pretenses open and fair
people who care are letting down their
defenses